all right guys bang-bang I have bill
here with us as I was joking with them
he is uh sitting on a boat in beautiful
blue waters and I'm sitting in New York
City trying not to get Cove in nineteen
so also have the same goals just
different locations absolutely for those
that don't know you let's just start
with the with your background it kind of
where you grew up and then how you got
into a finance okay so I grew up in
Jersey City New Jersey I went to school
in the University of Iowa and right
around my fourth year I'm a five year
graduate my godfather goes you know
basically gives me the what the hell are
you gonna do with your life kind of talk
which I was kind of delusional um you
know I knew I didn't want to do
engineering I went to school for
electrical engineering but I knew I
wanted to make money and I saw the movie
Wall Street I thought this is a way to
like leverage my time and make a bunch
of money so am I gonna stops he's like
uh I don't know anything about stocks I
know this commodity firm on the exchange
floor you want to go take a visit bring
your resume etc take a visit so long
story short I show off my resume they
take my resume they tear it up they vote
on the ground you don't need that here
they walk me around and I thought I had
a job I didn't have the job like there
was apparently somebody else flying for
the job so I used to come down to the
exchange for three days waiting like
okay good job calling you to go jump can
I get it I get in reading downstairs as
a peon like assistant assistant
assistant peon and you know I worked my
way up from there yeah and so when you
first got started did you go right into
the energy market or redoing something
else so I worked for a company called
refined energy that was in the crude oil
back then there was only crude oil
gasoline right those pits where they
were and uh and uh heating oil diesel
and so I was a screen clerk for that
firm that's where I started right and
that's where I started learning about
commodities and
sins etc working at different firms on
the floor yeah and I guess one of the
big leaps I think that every trader
wants to make is I want to go from
working for somebody else to eventually
starting my own stuff and kind of what
was that transition like because you
made a you you wrote a couple different
places and then eventually went out on
your own but cut out what drove that
that was like a Lim's of meandering
process right like I needed to learn I
need to stumble I wasn't brokering over
the counter which I hated although was
lucrative but I really hated it and then
I got offered to run an options desk in
Houston as they were deregulating
natural gas and needed traders to
basically manage risk so I I swear I
would never go to tax Texas like leaving
the Upper West Side to go to Texas was
like friends like what the hell are you
doing but I would went to Siberia to
trade you know I really really wanted to
be a trader I really wanted to be a
master of my own fate I really wanted to
eat what I killed not dependent on
people's moods but dependent on my
ability versus the markets and so I left
and through a long process you know
developed a name for myself either good
or bad right and worked with eventually
when Enron went under my friend John
Arnold was going to start this his fund
and I was like well if you paid this
percent I'll come work with you you know
what's true young guys trying to take on
the world and we started off four people
and since were starting this natural gas
trading shop and then that firm became
you know long story short the most
successful commodity hedge fund ever
aside from Rensselaer in commodity
trading right just a ridiculous run he
called him rich and retired and then I
started my own fund got and when you
guys started that was it something where
you were managing personal capital at
that point was it you had a couple LPS
and that really gave the confidence to
make the jump or did you guys start and
then have to go raise the money before
you can actually start trading so one of
the craziest things about Centaurus
success
was that I didn't have a dime of my own
money in the file which the logic at the
time which I now know is totally false
was that listen it's okay to have no
money and a job or a lot of money and no
job but no job and no money is pretty
bad and so the idea was if we blow up
and you have your money in here you know
that's a bad thing and so we didn't do
it but you know looking back I was so
young I was like I could easily recover
from this I should have taken the risk
okay and so John started sent tourists
with eight million dollars of his own
money and the investors that said they
were gonna put the money in day one they
didn't show up but after we posted a
hundred and seventy or whatever three
hundred percent return they started
knocking on the door right and then you
know the next year or whatever they kept
knocking on the door to the point where
it got to point with John's kicking
people out and not letting people in
like we he was able to get to a point
where each he was able to choose the
parking he wanted it I asked a very
well-known hedge fund manager I said how
do you guys raise so much money and he
said we don't and I said what do you
mean he goes we don't do [ __ ] the
returns raise the money right just you
don't come and find us because they want
the returns right it's very path
dependent - it's unfortunate because you
know no one bats a thousand a lot of
people have you know bad year or
whatever good thesis great bet we do it
a hundred times at 100 but if you have
that bad stub year of that bad first
year you just it's almost impossible to
raise money right and so that's the bad
side about raising outside capital you
know for sure and then talk a little bit
about when you actually went out on your
own
kind of why go out on your own and what
were some of the things you learned as
you did that um I thought you know that
I was avoiding FOMO partially right we
went Centaurus top-ranked Whaley who now
runs copper wood and I were gonna
partner together right by being the
second most successful trader at Copper
wood and a bunch of other all-stars is
there all officers you
he was gonna start the fund and the
bottom line is as Greg and I could not
agree on on control wrist limits etc
rightly Greg's Greg's a military guy
he's got he can only be one captain
right and so even though we're we're
great friends and we still talk a lot it
was better for me to go away and the
reason why is the pooling risk in
commodities
you know guys wanted me to stay for you
know having my set of neurons and my way
of thinking to help the fun but I was
like listen you could have your best
year ever and I could wipe you out right
because if I have a bad year I treat
such a big you know big book big style
you kind of want to be insulated from
that you think you want me but you don't
want it you know and we can always talk
shop right so you still get my neurons
right but you you don't you don't you
don't have the risk and so that's the
way it went got it and then when you
went out on your own you went right to
to all the energy stuff for retraining
other commodities as well no it's just
to treat what I know right like it would
be hard it would be very very hard for
us for me to raise money outside of you
know what I had been doing then it's
politi raising money so we were able to
get you know a big check from one
institution ambassador of fund of funds
and and we're still small teeny teeny
fine but and a couple other friends and
family and high net worth individuals
for sure and then as you've grown I
think you're also doing venture capital
investing now as well a little bit
yeah I do that through through my own
entity right I have enough capital to be
like I guess a medium-sized family
office and so I have a lot of in-house
expertise that I've hired over the years
to attack certain certain problems deal
with certain issues and so I have a CIO
I have you know capital to deploy and I
love solving puzzles so I've been doing
that I don't aside but it's not on the
side at the size we're doing it you know
I say it on the side because my primary
job is training natural gas and writing
training energy but you know we rewrite
what I would consider so what's
significant tickets you know when I go
into you know a publicly listed stock
and I look at how many shares I hold and
I'm like wow we're in the top if they
listened to us we'd be in the top top
ten right of shares you know and so and
when we come into a private placement
you know we're able to write the tickets
that people are looking for and the size
is right they don't want one single
investor to control it but they're
looking for half a million two million
to five million blocks you know we're
able to write that ticket so it's it's
gotten pretty serious you know it's
always serious right but it's gotten
it's significant
the unfortunate thing is is that we do
have a limited pool of capital and
there's lots of great things
yeah for sure let's talk a little bit
about what's going on in in the energy
natural gas world obviously things have
been absolutely chaotic hahaha to say
the least
kinda what are you seeing in the market
and how are you guys thinking about
what's going to transpire here coming in
the future
right like the two things the two things
that we're kinda is the demand
destruction going on from response to
Coba 19 versus supply destruction from
crude oil shut-ins and rigsby drop right
and so we have these opposing forces
happening right and it's chaotic right
people we're looking at like power burns
and supply getting turned back from LNG
versus shut ins versus nobody's doing
anything right and you know our general
thesis right now is that we used to be
extremely bearish the front of the curve
but we've tempered that because of the
rig count and shut ins and prices right
nothing here is high prices better than
high prices and nothing here's a blood
pendant in the glut right and so those
play you know the problem with our view
is is that there's a lot normally we're
very act like our error rate right we'll
say there's a half a B C of the day if
anybody know that's a billion cubic feet
a day for example the United States is
producing about 93 BC of the day right
so that's where we want to be in our
error rate link now our it's like to be
CF it takes really click it's very hard
to pinpoint a single variable how much
how much is production going to be from
a within to VCF today how much is you
know how much how much is demand
disruption right now within a bc of the
day no you know and what will be in the
future those are very hard to predict
but if you have an overwhelming
overwhelming cumulative factor like
supply declines we believe as time goes
on at this low of a rig cow the supply
to climb will overwhelm all other
factors as we get further out right and
so we have this kind of like very
nuanced view of the world as time moves
for yeah I was gonna sad I don't know
too many people who I've heard say that
before so maybe describe like explain
that a little bit more as to what you
mean exactly by that yeah let me let me
uh I guess if if you had a I love
bathtub analogies but this is if you had
a bathtub right and it's about to
overflow right you're like oh my gosh is
there's nobody using this water it's
flowing into nobody's drew
it's all flowing into this tub and his
stuff flow and the dreams of this big
great and then at the same you know at
the same time you're like the dream gets
a little bigger and the flow keeps going
down down down down down until there's
no flow right so in the short term maybe
some spills over the sides and we have a
price crash right but over the long term
we can see the what is gonna stop and
the drain is still there right and it's
gonna get very you know it's going to be
very bullish water like where's a lot
right and so that's the way it is in
natural gas is that the faucet of
natural gas is is slowing down and the
drain is staying the same or maybe
getting a little bigger and so how that
plays out over time is is complex right
like well well will it overflow before
you know you mean like is it gonna
overflow in the short term or not or
just gonna just be okay
right and then as we get into the high
demand periods of natural gas which is
really the winner and as we go further
in time you know we need to start
worrying about running out of water
right there's no water in the tub right
and so that's kind of hope that analogy
helps but that's kind of the way we're
looking at the market right now what is
the overwhelming long-term variable and
what's gonna happen in a shorter ya know
that makes a lot of sense and I guess
how much of that are you focused just on
the United States versus a lot of the
things that are going internationally
with Saudi Russia and kind of a lot of
the stuff that they're trying to to
manipulate you know over time you know
the u.s. used to import natural gas it
still does in every open up in Boston
but the over the years we've gone from
importing to exporting seven and a half
going up to eight to ten DC everyday
great so that's a significant number so
that has forced every single natural gas
trader to pay attention to what's going
on in the world we used to love our
market because it was a niche market
that was complex enough that the average
person couldn't figure it out but you
could if you built the phone and
built-in resources right there weren't
that many variables and now there's this
extra
variable of what's happening
internationally are they gonna basically
turn back all the LNG that we're
shipping to them thus complicating our
situation here so we're very much aware
you know we build AI ship models and
track the models of fundamentals in
Europe and also try and figure out
what's going in Asia and that black box
tracking ships etc because we need to
know okay when Europe says when the
price of European gas goes below us gas
as it is right now we need to know how
many cargo is going to wind up at our
doorstep thus putting pressure on the
price right and so we've all been forced
to go to school very quickly on
international markets yeah it's super
interesting and I guess as part of this
like what would change your mind about
the thesis on where natural gas is going
now or there's certain things that you
guys are looking at is either kind of
flags or or things that you're like hey
if X happens then we would actually
change our thesis yeah I mean we're
we're we're concerned about the level of
like you know most of these things are
highly educated guesses right so you
know I've gone from bearish the front to
mildly supportive right with with
massive ever right in baked in there and
you know I would look at okay we're
measuring the supply every day and is it
is it declining at the rate right and
that's one of those slow boiling frogs
you don't know cuz it's noisy you have
to get a bunch of data we're looking at
how quickly the US opens or doesn't open
up this is kind of keep opening and
shutting up right up with it affected in
demand equation we're looking at
international prices like what's gonna
happen with these LNG ships in these
turn backs right we have a count
immediate reports but it could be bigger
right we could say looks like it's to a
nap needs a day but what if it's five
right and so these things are things
that in a short-term we're watching for
the long term the biggest thing is rig
count if you don't have rigs drilling
you can't you can't overcome two
declines so I think I don't know people
know this but when you drill a natural
gas well you have this
i production and then it starts to
decline pretty steep
great and so we have to do we have to
find 18 i think it's 18 bc yesterday 16
18 DC yesterday I'll have the number
exactly just to stem the clients right
so we need rigs out there running just
so it doesn't decline and so when you
take the rigs down more than 50 percent
which we've done you know in three weeks
it's just amazing how how much we've
stopped drilling and you know
stop that stop fractures going out
producing gas that over time becomes
just an overwhelming factor so the main
thing I look at every day is whatever it
gets done what are we toasting you know
and then I do further research how long
does it take recounts to go up versus
down break this is easy to drop a rig
we're dropping rigs how long does it
take to get the crew back out back on
the pad etc and then and grow it and so
every day that I see the rig cow drop
and stay at this level the more bullish
I become the back how much of the rigs
going down is driven by like Ovid 19
social distancing stuff versus the
economy and natural prices dropping and
so then it becomes unprofitable I think
it's I think it's 99.9% prices a
response to prices and what's going on
in oil so we have a lot of the natural
gas producers produced by associated gas
associated gas basically you're drilling
for oil and gas comes out with right and
so the oil is the higher priced product
and gas is kind of a pipeline right to
extent that you know they're flaring gas
in the Permian INBOX well lo and behold
oil goes to crap you know you don't get
that free bribe product a gas flowing
right and also so you have a lot of
those rigs dropping right and a lot of
balance sheets impaired by companies
that drill both for natural gas and oil
and so they're dropping rates right they
have to get them they have to lower the
budget staff to survive and therefore
tight
balance et cetera and so that activity
that's what's driving you know the drop
another race kovat is the indirect cause
right because there's no demand yeah for
sure and I guess part of this is just
like you're trying to calculate you know
how quickly can you get the crews back
out and get the rig's back up and
running there's also this calculation of
like they can say the cities are open or
the states are open but actually how
long does it take for consumers to start
demanding or consuming right yeah and we
can measure real-time demand so we were
able to measure a real-time electricity
demand real-time you know we can see
power burns every day every minute so
we're tracking the demand pretty well
right it's hard to forecast like it kept
you kind of get worse but we're tracking
it pretty well and have a reasonable
idea of what the bottom is right New
York City's completely shut down but
it's the power demand is down 11% so we
kind of know right so the main thing
right now is like okay when does this
faucet become a problem right when does
the supply issue become a problem right
now it's not a problem not a problem at
all
matter of fact is the exact opposite we
might have too much gas but that switch
is gonna flip and when it flips given
the current circumstances if we stay on
this path it could be violent to the
upside yeah and so what it sounds like
you're really kind of highlighting right
now you've got a surplus from a supply
side demand has gone down a little bit
but because you realize you've got the
surplus and demands down people are
actually shutting down production
support incoming supplies almost slowing
and so when that demand comes flying
back there could be a moment in time
where people are caught without enough
supply and that's what the problem would
come in yeah like people are just
starting cutting the production and
associated so you know these guys you
know also the costs the break-even cost
and well is change right if you look at
the interest cost you know drilling is a
leveraged business right and you know
there's been studies done in the
Marcellus like what are the break-even
at different interest rates
but if you look at like the cost of
capital for the drillers they basically
have doubled on average so I don't know
if the the price break evens you know
get you to what you want the supply you
want and so that that's another thing
I'm looking at but generally right now
you know I say there's things like
there's tweezer trades where you have to
be really accurate and really nuanced
know every single little detail and
there's sledgehammer trees huge macro
thing is happening you don't need all
the details you have enough room for our
you just pile it right and I think the
further we get in time this goes from
tweezers to sledgehammer great for sure
let's switch gears a little bit you um
you not only spent a lot of time
obviously paying attention to the
markets and in trading but uh you also
played a lot of Poker and kind of where
did that fascination come from and
really it looks like you just enjoy it
so like when did you kind of get into
poker I think I got into poker or any
kind of wagering on the floor right it's
a very you know locals and traders
around it's a very degenerate type
attitude right like they're playing the
house generally but that feeling that
emotion of like taking risk the risk
takers and so I have that gene you know
that risk-taking gene that degeneracy
and I just kind of got into that you
know of being able to let go and take
risks right and and be able to get lucky
and then as the stakes got higher and
the money that's like wait a minute I
need to stop trying to get lucky and
actually trying to be the house just a
little bit learning poker and just get a
little bit better but I do
I do love poker because you you play
with very interesting people it's a
social game right it's a competitive
social game that you use your math
skills and your cunning and intellect
but you're also interacting with some
very very interesting people and you get
to meet some interesting people and
characters playing poker for sure and I
guess as part of the
like at what point did you make the
switch from probably playing like games
with friends and more kind of what I'll
call the amateur levels to consciously
saying hey I want to go playing the
bigger games I want to go playing the
tournaments with the public you know
publicly available or private like what
was that kind of ambition I think it's
the same delusion I had as being a
traitor right like it's totally
delusional right to go I'm gonna be this
multi-millionaire traitor and I'm gonna
go and I'm gonna do X Y Z I like happen
to do it right you know my I'm I'm here
to do it I have you know slightly
elevated chance of being successful but
I don't think I'm that special right I
just think that I have that motivation
and a delusion like you gotta have the
delusion to try and so I think I had
that delusion in the beginning like I
want to try I could be I could be that
guy I could you know I could beat this
guy but a lot of money I can win a
tournament how hard could it be type of
thing you know and you know through the
school of hard knocks you figure out
it's it's very hard but if you're
persistent you can get better and better
and better and better it's like you're
always getting better right you can
always studying me better for sure
what's your favorite game they've ever
played um in terms of like No Limit
Hold'em or like on I think like the
televised we used to play this game
where it was called not the wild card
but they would have these televised
things where they would bring somebody
in and give them a chance to play and
sharks right and you'd sit there and
they got to keep the money they won and
I I really love that concept that I
really loved playing on the shows and I
you know it changed people's lives you
know it I really love those televised
poker shows where people who wouldn't
have the means to playing those games
get a chance and keep the money won it's
great for the game brings out awareness
and - I just love rooting for the I love
that and it also brings in the
the whole element of there's everybody
out there things they can beat the
people on TV right whether it's
basketball poker or anything else and so
give them a shot no yeah yeah the only
one where people just will not go do
that is embossing they just know they
will get their ass right but like I say
is like you know they still break the
checks whether you could you ask if
they're not so when we were kids we used
to joke all the time and say how much
money would it take for you to stand in
the ring with Mike Tyson for 30 seconds
not even fight back
for 30 seconds well how much money would
it take yeah yeah that's one of those
bunches of priests yeah you know
absolutely one of the most asked
questions that I had people no one
really wanted tweet they were all like
DMing me this was they said ask Bill to
tell the wildest poker story that he 10
that he's never told before and so I
don't really know I'm gonna ask them
that other than just flat-out ask them
so you got any wild stories you've never
told before wild stories I mean I can't
because my kids might see this I can't I
mean ideas a story I wouldn't tell you g
I mean aa involves me dan Bilzerian Sam
McGee a bunch of interesting ladies and
at his house late at night and I just
can't I can't I can't do it by I guess I
mean the the other Wild Ones are really
just money swings for people just doing
ludicrous things right like just you
know sitting out all in 3:6 off you know
we're shipping it in two hundred
thousand like what's going on here like
I'm clearly not rich enough you know
like that type of thing but the true
story would have to be my daughter's
have to be a little bit older all right
that's fair enough fair enough
as you kind of think about investing in
the venture capital side also company
we're interested
you know poker is you're playing a
multifaceted game right it's not just
the math of the cards you're also making
decisions without all the information
you're playing off of other people at
the table and it's very similar to
venture capital investing where you've
got to make those decisions without all
the information you gotta have some
confidence you got to have some
probability understanding like what are
some of the lessons that you've learned
from poker that you've brought over on
the investing side that you think will
be helpful for others I think that
bankroll management is very important
for like in the professional poker space
risk you know I mean you know they're
very similar right in terms of risk
reward limited information you know
sometimes you know the market can be you
know it's when you put on a position in
the market it's not like oh I'm ready I
did all my homework and then the trade
goes my way right there's the market who
goes no we're gonna be idiots and jam it
up in your face or you know make make
this treat whiskey or for you you know
any means so you got Kings and a guy's
jamming all the time you like cuz we
have aces this great you know limited
information and you just have to
probability weight things and risk
management budget management bankroll
management all these things go back and
forth and I always say it's easier for a
poker player to become like a VC or a
commodities trader than a magistrate or
VC it explain that more what why do you
think that I just think that um the
school of hard knocks and poker in terms
of bankroll management managing your
risk manage your emotions is the main
thing like when people say you know X
rated what does it take to be a trader I
said highest highest level it's a
psychology test
right cuz nothing changes you just react
to the market it's like do you do the
right thing you know are you thinking
correctly are you making the right
decisions or when you have a bad day are
you chasing are you doing something
other than just what math risk
management and fundamentals tell you to
do right are you making excuses and you
know Hoecker trade you not to be
results-oriented not to you know go on
tilt right not to act out a board or
more etc it's all about the money etc
and those skill sets translate well into
trading right you're gonna carry that
over because it's your own role and
you've been dealing with that as a
trader you come over to poker and you're
like you know you know stuff like that
and so I just think that those lessons
if you learn them in poker translate
very well into invest right very well in
terms of like market chaos like we're
seeing right now what are the things
that you do to kind of control those
emotions or control your psychology to
make sure that you actually are thinking
clearly and making sound decisions um I
I try to come out of appreciation like
if you take everything away away from me
like I have my health I'm able to love
my kids you know I have love and I give
love you know and so I come from
appreciation like where I came from
where I did and what I have no matter
what you take away right I could at
least breathe rate so once I detach
myself from the ego of you off the money
or you did this or what people think I I
can't think clearly rate I can start
doing announce like okay the market just
dropped um 30 percent if I and I'm
buying company XY and Z okay so let's
say I thought they were gonna pay me $10
a month for for 30 years but now these
first three years gonna be zero what's
this change in the NPV right so that's
an irrational thought right like okay
we're gonna have
the company's going to survive it's just
not gonna have revenues for the next
three years but it's going to survive
how did that change the NPV and if the
markets down 30 in the NPV shoot down 17
I can rationally think that this is a
bargain right I should be buying and
there were actually many you know we ran
that exercise right it's a sledgehammer
exercise but we ran an exercise on a
bunch of companies that were we are not
going bankrupt right may have impaired
sales break uh clearly you know and the
market punished them on you know what's
an overreaction it's like we're a buyer
and there were certain companies like no
it's not gonna survive it may not
survive this is actually a sick this is
actually a sale right without a bailout
or a sold sell like it has debt do it's
over levered this thing should collapse
right and and that's a sale and so being
able to like remove what's happening to
me you know and stay focused outward
focus on the problem it is is what I try
and do you know in the end and knowing
that hey I'm really really lucky like I
live in the United States of America
hi infrastructure you know event at buy
worse worse worse scenario where I'm
waiting tables or something like I'm
okay great and so once I remove that
like panic about me what's happened to
me what's happened to my money then I
can focus to start making great
decisions yeah how do you think about
like the dislocation right now in the
market where it seems like stocks are
you know relief rallying if not really
rallying but the economic data we keep
getting is going down right 26 million
Americans unemployed 4.8% contraction
and q1 for the economy like it just
seems like the underlying data and the
actual reality on the ground is way
worse than the stock market which seems
to just be going in the opposite
direction yeah I think usually we have
scenarios like this where the government
comes in intervenes it drives the wealth
gap right and so I think they could
current like rally broadly speaking is
asset inflation right and so there is a
massive effort of to inflate the value
of assets and it's you can't you just
can't fight that right and so that's
where you're gonna see this stock is up
we're doing XY and Z or doing well or
hitting these funds why this guy is
unemployed etc right and so those who
own stock XYZ do well or bought it let
the dip this guy still doesn't have a
job right and so you see that divergence
in in unfortunately in times like this
with the government action it usually
drives the wealth gap it doesn't no
close yeah it feels almost like it
reiterates the point of the stock
markets not the economy it's just the
central bank actions or represents right
how do you think about the bailouts and
that government intervention the the
next step of that I I'm generally i I'm
not on the pamp that the government
should do nothing but what the
government is doing I am generally 100
percent yes
you know I am there's a lot of companies
that you know a lot of people have the
idea like if this airline fails then we
will have an airline and and that's just
not true they when you're when somebody
goes boss with their house the house
doesn't disappear just a new owner shows
up right that guy disappears and so you
know with the airline's these owners
that created this highly leveraged
position right spend all their capital
buying back their stock didn't think
about like you know the robustness of
the stability which is okay I'm not even
gonna mop that it's okay if you want to
do that but you have to accept the risk
when something goes wrong in a levered
scenario you go bust you don't get your
executive bonus you get fired you
management comes in bondholders get
smashed they should have been paying
attention and the equity guys get wiped
out but the airlines are still there and
somebody will gladly come in put in some
capital and run it running right and so
what we've done is we've removed that
right we removed that punishment and I'm
against it I would much rather have all
that money just be direct deposits into
the
individuals pockets right which actually
helps close the wealth gap and then let
that money trickle into triple up into
whatever investments or whatever is out
there right but now we're flowing money
into concentrated
pockets of businesses in industries
right we're picking winners and losers
and letting them distribute the money as
they see fit
yeah it feels like that what I know
about you I think they very much kind of
the United States is is the best country
in the world we have a significant
advantage around the American Dream and
kind of that belief that like we're all
entitled to move up in the world but it
feels like when you start to take away
the impact of risk-taking right the
actual negative side effects of when you
take risk and it doesn't work your way
you change the incentive structure right
and it almost feels like you start to
create this social safety net or
corporate safety net that really almost
incentivizes more bad behavior moreover
leveraging if you know someone's gonna
bail you out every time yeah it also
like it hurts other guys and other
competitors who don't get picked maybe I
have Joe upstart Airlines and I like
Haiti and leverage ratio is pretty crazy
and their customer service is [ __ ]
and you're building up your customers
right I don't know what airline you are
call it spirit clips not not spirit
because there's a lot of people
experience but you don't mean but and
you're like great this is my shot to
tape over like I'm going to get those
slots at Newark and I'm gonna get those
slots at iah and my airlines gonna grow
but here comes the government with seven
point eight billion dollars or seventy
two billion dollars you know it's a
better line that airline that airline
and you get squashed while they get
rewarded right and so not only that's
the incentive structure changed it just
solidifies incumbents right who probably
shouldn't be there right and just it
just it crushes the American dream for a
lot of people a lot of people don't
realize like there's people
organizations entrepreneurs upstarts
right coming out to compete who are not
getting the billions of dollars right
and now it makes their job even harder
almost
possible in certain cases right you're
almost in a situation where the
government's playing kingmaker to some
degree right there correct you know
picking winners and the other data point
that I saw recently that just blew my
mind was there's a lot of workers that
are asking to be fired from various
companies because they can make more on
unemployment with the stimulus kind of
beefed up in the unemployment insurance
then they will at their normal job and
it feels like that's just one not
something that I ever would have thought
was possible but two it's kind of sad to
see right where people are literally
saying hey fire me from my job because I
literally can make more money on
unemployment than you're paying me to
actually show up here yeah that that's
that's interesting you know um I'm a fan
of like some sort of floor UVI great I'm
at the point where I think that survival
just basic survival should not be
dependent on a job great all the land is
taken is no living off the land and
farming and all that kind of stuff so
you're kind of forced into the structure
where if you want to survive and eat you
have to have a job great and I think a
lot of people will culturally say yeah
but of course but it wasn't that way
right that's not how America started you
do not have to go work for somebody okay
in order to survive most people work for
themselves right went out went out in
the West settled grew their crops
whatever that that is gone you can't do
that and so there's this force element
to work like you must work or else you
cannot survive right and I think that
should be eliminated right and I'm not
saying peace be lavish I'm saying like
at the poverty level great where you can
survive and I think that work should be
for thriving that being said these
levels of unemployment you know where
I'm paying here you know I don't know if
that's an indictment on unemployment or
what they're paying employees but I
think that's a little bit absurd yeah
Timmy day I think that was the part that
I took away from it right was the fact
that the wages that a lot of folks that
are obviously asking to be fired yeah
to be solo right it's not the you know
$15 an hour type thing you got to be
talking about people who are probably
making you know 8 to 10 bucks an hour in
today's environment you know it's just
sad frankly right but and those are
people that like hey I would rather work
on my play or my theory of physics or
whatever it is they can work on if they
had some if their survival was taken
care of right if you you knew you were
gonna survive you know I think that
would unleash a lot of creativity and
entrepreneurship out of the populace and
not force them to work in McDonald's
versus working on this brilliant cure
for X Y & Z that's going to take five
years right and so um that that's the
crushing thing like people are missing
about like having a floor and take
eliminating work from survival is you
actually unleash a ton of risk-taking
and entrepreneurship and you unlock the
creativity of many people right there's
so many people who are in soul-sucking
low-paying jobs just because they gotta
buy ramen noodles and beans and if they
had their ramen noodles and beans taken
away they would say fu to that job right
and work on whatever they were working
on which I think society would benefit
for sure what's your thoughts on like
all the quantitative easing and kind of
the central bank's response to a lot of
this just in terms of it seems like they
could just print and print and print and
there's no end in sight I am generally
against like I said it favors rich guys
like right guys who have assets and
houses you know when you devalue money
you know you value assets right and you
know I hear arguments like on Twitter's
like yeah but it helps the poor because
their debt is lower I'm like the wages
don't go higher okay their wages are not
going higher okay and everything they
buy is getting more expensive right and
their debt is still the same it hurts
the poor 100% the poor don't have
$300,000 mortgages
the $200,000 mortgages and and placement
adjustments in their paycheck right
right nobody's getting the guaranteed
CPI adjusted wage right and so it's just
terrible you know and I think like if it
ever gets in a situation where the world
goes violent over the wealth gap I'm
gonna be like don't blame me I was
against you know I was against all this
inflationary crap that hurts right I
just think it's I just think it's
terrible it's just plain terrible yeah
and part of you know what the last year
or so I've really kind of pounded the
drum on that I think is so interesting
is like every single person that has any
degree of wealth that I talk with or any
amount of assets they all understand
this right and what was very quickly
become obvious to me is there's this big
education gap as well right cuz the
bottom 50% or so of Americans who can't
afford the 400 or emergency payment or
whatever believe that's are they
actually don't understand how money
works they don't understand that all
that quantitative easing is stealing the
wealth devaluing their savings and
things like that it's the people who
have the assets they get it right and
whether they agree with it or not they
understand how the game works and so
they're gonna position themselves to be
protected to benefit except Chara and it
almost feels like the system is
dependent on a big portion of people not
understanding how it works to some
degree oh oh yeah there's there's a
couple good quotes I should get into it
but if people knew how the money they
have their money work they would yeah I
mean they kill the king
right they kill it there is I am
actually shocked at how financially
illiterate public generally is right if
I say net present value you know like
simple things like I it's not like they
don't have the masculist they do because
you know you've had to learn these
things it's just that this is not taught
it doesn't seem to be a priority uh and
it's so important to like even just your
daily life like should I
have money in this bank account in my
savings account while I have credit card
debt like it's very simple thing greatly
you don't carry 24 foot sink you know
you don't pay it I mean to have cash in
the bank you use your credit for
anything you want another cash
withdrawal you can take it out at any
time but there are so many people
friends of mine that I'm just saying
what are you doing you know what are you
doing you're you're paying to have money
in a bank they don't get it and so I
don't know it's just sad it's sad like I
think a lot of my discussions like
people are you know I get into the
lady's Twitter battles I love Twitter
I'm addicted to swith uh people like
white white they're like why are you
arguing with this troll like why are you
doing X Y & Z and the reason is is that
there are other people reading that
discussion and I want them to learn I
want them to know right and so as long
as we can have a civil conversation I
can hopefully help somebody else to go
either investigate further or learn
about what's going on and dispel the
myths that are getting thrown around for
sure you will you live a fun life Oh
talk a little bit about kind of the
lifestyle stuff and kind of how you've
structured your life to to enjoy it now
rather than you know kind of working
every single day inside of a normal
office yeah like uh you know the great
thing about technology is is that you
know people work and I've been remote
for a while right and so everything from
the applications we build in-house to
other trading applications I have on my
phone so the good thing is is that I can
be anywhere and work from anywhere the
bad thing is is I could be anywhere and
work from anywhere right so it's it's a
double-edged sword but you know my
favorite thing in the world to do is
travel so that's there's a kibosh on
that right now
and you know I spend most of my time
trying to change what my office looks
like
right oh go to Tokyo just in Petersburg
or go to Europe you know that's kind of
all on hold right now
and so I'm in the Virgin Islands where
you know at least I can get on the water
you know
you know I'm out here with all the other
boats oh look you know I'm hanging out
here if you can see that do you see that
yeah of course yeah and so and you know
that's I just kind of go where I like
and just try and be at peace the water
and the animals and sea life is I'm at
peace here for sure and then you've got
this kind of idea I know you got a book
coming out over the summer but died with
zero right maybe kind of explain what
that concept really means and kind of
how you put it into into practice well
so independently I've been thinking
about like the utility of money and what
what it's for right you spend hours of
your life it exceeds for money in order
to do things to have experiences the
first experience is survival great you
want to survive you want to feed
yourself shelter health whatever and
then the other is other experiences that
you want to have whether that's putting
your kids to college or going on a trip
or buying baseball cards or going to a
show right we're all working in order to
exchanging hours of life in order to
have other experiences okay and so it
stands to reason that if I go to work to
acquire money to have experiences but
then die I just wasted hours of my life
right like I just why did I go to work
for money that I'm never gonna use and
so you know it quickly sit in my head
that you want to die with you want to
die you want to use all your resources
before you die and I'm not the first
person to think about this economists
called full lifecycle hypothesis or full
life cycle theory basically rational
people will aim to die with zero okay
and then the other part of it that I
stuck into it that was thinking about is
is that you know as I've seen people in
my life my dad my grandmother and other
people age right and then when you look
at the data your ability to extract
positive life experiences you know have
experiences declines as you age like I
tell people the memory of playing
football right now is greater than
actually playing football right now
right and so that will happen with all
experiences
sex like you'll be at a certain age like
it's a great time back in my 30s but
trying to have sex then might be like I
don't want to break a hip
I don't want to you know need like
whatever it is and so not only is there
hey you should aim to spend all your
money before you die you have to get the
timing right great you know you don't
want to go heli-skiing at 90 probably
want to scheme between you know 30 and
50 I'm just using extreme examples right
and there's always outliers so I don't
want to get into that but I'm just
saying on the whole right there's a
season for you to do different
activities and making sure that you
allocate your resources properly within
each season is important you know and
I've been saying it a lot lately I said
life is like Tetris great you got to get
the order right in order to get the most
points right in order to get the most
the fullest life so anybody who's like
hey I'm gonna wait till 90 to go hike
Kilimanjaro and then go to see
cheeseburger can do whatever they got it
wrong right that money was meant to be
spent now and a lot of people actually
do that and what happens is what you see
is those who save save too much people's
net worth keep growing into their 70s
and 80s and it's like what are they
waiting right for sure in that sense I
think you recently turned 50 years old
right what's left on kind of your bucket
list or what are the things that you say
hey you know these are the things that I
want to do in the next 10 years right so
I try and break them up in categories
and I actually have a beta version one
of like bucket your life because each
time bucket matters you know one of the
things is like as writing this book
thinking about it like holy [ __ ] I need
to listen to the same things I'm talking
about right like not be the fat coach on
the sidelines like you know me like
who's all out of shape you know but it's
the coach that was me right and so I'm
like wait a minute I have spent time
with my daughter's these are the
activities I want to do etc these are
the places I want to travel things I
want to investigate projects I want to
work on charities I want to help or
problems I want to solve you know I've
kind of put them in
those buckets and so travel this way
number one for me which is really you
know nobody's gonna play the violin for
me I'm super lucky but I'm like oh you
mean like not being able to travel as a
crusher so now I'm like refocusing on
personal relationships helping people
and charities and helping solving
problems you know research projects and
just learning you know and loving and
keeping contact when my personal
relationships so it's been a great quiet
time to actually do that with family and
be forced to be stuck in a house you
know and being with two teenage girls in
a house this it's not easy but every day
I'm like this is great you know yeah we
had a blowout battle screaming and
yelling and then crying and then yelling
whatever but like this is great like I'm
gonna look back one day and be like this
was the best of times and so I'm just
learning to live in gratitude right now
and then I'm planning when it's opens up
to really really travel like really burn
it and travel and you know learn other
cultures and go to places I haven't been
and visit some places that are high on
my list that I love I have your
daughter's got you on on tick tock yet
if they pulled in any of the dance
videos I mean they're on tick-tock
they're doing dance videos they do not
want me on it they they I used to be a
cool dad to them but now like it
embarrasses them like all my friends
follow you on Instagram I can't stand it
they're always saying something you know
no she needs are like anything I do
wrong or that's like not cool or
girlfriend's boobs or showing or
whatever they're like you know whatever
it is right and so they they hate that
like coming out and I might be more
recognizable it's just it annoys them
well the worst part is probably all the
girls probably say stuff that or are
their age and then the guys all pile of
you right they're like I want to do that
stuff yeah then they don't like it like
they have you know I thought like a lot
of their guy friends they like kind of
want to meet me or say hi or whatever at
that very instant I'm
cool they like it but it still annoys
them they're like no don't come cuz
everybody's gonna want to talk to you
and they want it to be about them yeah
they feel as if I'm ruining their high
school experience you know and I don't
want to ruin their high school
experience you know I it's kind of weird
you know but it's the way it is you know
but we all been in school and pretty
much anything can ruin it right like
literally could throw it off yeah yeah
and so I'm trying not to ruin it I'm
trying to protect them raise them well
whatever probably doing it like 70
percent wrong but I'm their new denim I
think I'm their absolute battle all
right man listen where do you wanna
people to go in terms of sending them to
either check out the book when it comes
out or or find out more about what you
guys do on the investing side yeah I
think um I mean I don't know if our
website's been updated for small
ventures usa.com that's thing you know
but that's where you know a lot of
people like who do I talk to them like
you know all the links or whatever
you'll get to the right person to to get
the deal through it and then die would
zero book die with zero book calm for
the book but unfortunately or
fortunately maybe because bookstores are
closed right now and that's a
significant portion of book sales even
though I'm you know the online isn't
making up for the you know the amount
that's gone from physical sales but July
28th it's coming out and you can
pre-order and I appreciate it you know
and I I think he will appreciate it too
because a lot of people are spending a
lot of money you know whether it's the
state your insurance or yourself to
extend your life for three months in a
hospital bed with a little quality of
life I'm like you know that's kind of
backwards take all that money put it
into good health years create memories
have those memory dividends with people
and really live a full life and [ __ ] the
three months in the hospital but I don't
remember where I heard this but I
adopted it as a life my two years ago
was anything worth doing is worth
overdoing
if you think through everything that you
do in your life if it's worth there
it's absolutely worth overdoing it to
some degree yeah and I think like living
your life to the fullest is definitely
one of the things you want to do while
you have your house you know for sure I
wrap up each conversation with two
questions for you and then you get to
ask me one the first is what is the most
important book you've ever read Wow Wow
this is this is a I'm gonna tie it I'm
gonna tie it with two um before
agreements is probably edging out your
money or your life so one is a financial
book and one is like holistic approach
about life so The Four Agreements is
number one that's my number one
recommended book and your money or your
life which kind of started the fire
movement you know financial independence
to retire early I don't I don't know if
you've heard of that but um that book
completely changed the way I look at
money and personally and also
professional rate and led to further
discoveries and questions etc right and
so and it it it's why I went into
training it's my understanding of
leverage you know not leverage just of
money but leverage of time right okay
when we got when somebody makes a lot of
money while she's doing this like time
is leveraged one minute of my time is
like one hour of that guy stop right and
we're just exchanging time and so that
understanding that concept and how money
works allows me to you know really you
know really really changed my life and
the four agreements is like really
change have you ever seen the movie uh
in time with Justin Timberlake yeah I
thought it was okay it could have been
better I love the concept though so um
that's basically it right is like the
concept gave thought on but at the end
yeah it could have done the story better
or whatever but if the concept was great
I was really looking forward to it and
you know your money or your life it's a
little didactic cuz it's really trying
to hammer in the point and change when
you're trying to change people's
cultural views and what they've already
or you know what they've accepted via
osmosis and everything around them you
have to be didactic you have to be
repetitive because they won't get it so
but still that book is a must must must
must must must be awesome alien believer
or non-believer in some sort of
intelligent life out there I I think I
think the answer is believer but we'll
never know so I mean if something's you
know a billion light years away you're
not gonna know great even if it's five
hundred light years away you're just
never gonna know right like and so yes I
have this kind of almost religious
belief that it's just you know the
numbers just are so large that it must
be but the you know the idea that you
we're gonna get in contact or capture
see even if they were sending signals
it's like you know very very very very
unlikely you're gonna grab so I don't
know I think s that's something
satisfying answer you know it's good I
actually almost forgot to ask you
thoughts on Bitcoin that was another one
that everyone wants to know what were
your thoughts on Bitcoin I'm kind of
nibbling I'm actually long it proxy
because I'm longest cut this company I
bought the stock very teeny company
called silver gate partners and simply a
capital S I on a york stock receives
they actually had good results today a
release that's already bank yeah yeah
that's one si symbols si and they
basically have a platform where they
they're one of the niche players where
they provide lending to institutions
trading Bitcoin clearing and they're now
starting this product to offer them some
leverage because they need to have both
Bitcoin and cash on every exchange that
they trade and so you know banks are all
about capital efficiency so the leverage
product may work and so I'm like you
know I'd rather be long the shovel maker
than the gold miner yeah
like III think Bitcoin can you know I'm
not I was once longing what up to 17,000
and then I ran some calculations and I
was like well be impossible to redo the
blockchain right and then I did some
calculations and I was like well if you
bought this amount of money great if you
spent this amount of money on servers
you can rehash the block
break at this value right in this time
and that just kind of gave me a sense of
this thing is overvalued went back then
one of the 17,000 great and you know
it's an adoption phenomenon it's a
marketing thing is will people keep and
believe in Bitcoin and will it grow and
I really don't know you know I hear
arguments for yes I hear arguments for
no but in the meanwhile I'm like well
this is a bank
these guys are trading it it's not gonna
get hurt it's very conservative it's
making revenues off a Bitcoin you know
not by you know if the price goes up
that means more people are trading
they'll make more money if it's volatile
goes up and down they make more money
because people are eating it if he based
business I'd rather be on that side and
be long it so I'm quasi long bit you
know looking especially if it's a hey I
don't know it's actually a pretty pretty
rational position to take Alan the CEO
so Gates been uh been on the podcast and
is you know credit to him I think back
in like two thousand and thirteen or
fourteen he really saw the opportunity
and kind of moved that entire Bank into
let's be the the player here because the
largest banks won't be and it's proved
to be a a pretty good decision for them
obviously yeah it's great and it's like
you know it's like it doesn't matter
what it is if it's beanie babies right
like it's like I don't care where baby
babies are going I'm still making money
servicing the beanie baby crowd right
until until it goes away or you know it
stays around and so III like I like what
he's done he's visionary maybe he's a
believer in the price level up and
that'll be great for his business but
they are a niche player where other
people just don't want to deal with all
the KYC and the [ __ ] they don't want
to get involved into it right and so I
think
it makes sense what one question do you
have for me to finish this up why did
you get into podcasting and do you still
like it
I thought the star in the podcast before
but I had I had some kids coming to me
who basically like hey you should do a
podcast and I had listened to a couple
podcasts but knew nothing that went into
it literally was like my mom always said
you know I had the face for radio giving
me a hard time but uh why the hell would
I do this and we record a couple of
episodes and released it and was
immediately people started listening I
was at wait a second you're telling me
that I can go sit in a room talk to
somebody just have a microphone there
and hit publish and like everyone else
gets excited and I don't have to like
sit and write and then like edit you
know my writing and like all of the work
that goes into publishing like much more
kind of higher production stuff
especially when you're writing and so
for whatever reason I was just like well
let's do another one let's do another
one and here we are I think we've done
like over 280 of them in about a year
and a half or so and I enjoy it because
it's it's two things for me and I always
said like it's very selfish right so
first is you and I probably wouldn't
talk unless I had the podcast so there's
this element of like I get to meet a lot
of people who are kind of tangentially
related to what I do and obviously I
learn from them I get ask them questions
and and all of that so that's super
valuable to me and then the second thing
is as I've started to do this I just
began to realize like you could go on
CNBC and all of the ideas you have in
your head they may give you five minutes
right and that would be like a long
segment well it might give me two and
and it's not you know to pick on CNBC
specifically it's just all of those kind
of television formats
they're very hitch driven around kind of
salacious comments it's very you know
cutting up a lot of different segments
is you still have a lot of time to
explain your ideas and and I think these
kind of longer form podcasts really
allow people to share their ideas in
their words without being interrupted
and explain what they mean or it's one
thing for you to say hey you know I
think that the money printing is not a
good situation okay what does that mean
and when you explain that you get the
content
and ends up being much more valuable
content I think for people who really
are just trying to learn so I enjoy it
and I'll keep doing it until one day I
wake up and it's not fun and then I'll
just drag our guys that was good run see
you yeah well that's great that's great
and I totally agree with you like a bit
on CNBC before and it's just like what
blurb headline thinking you get out and
you when you don't explain and give
context like you know people twist it
right like I'm against the money
printing oh these against helping
Americans you know no so yeah I get it I
appreciate you and the other podcast is
doing this getting out there it's super
entrepreneurial it's awesome for sure so
we will send people over to go check out
the book and appreciate doing this yeah
anytime hope everybody got value out of
it